our second speaker this morning is uh
miriam valman who's from uh iqoqi
in vienna which stands for institute for
quantum optometry
quantum optics and quantum information
and she's going to tell us about
self-tests of physical theories
and foundations of quantum theory
thanks mary
well thanks a lot thanks a lot um for
inviting me um and to give this talk i'm
very excited to be here and it's been
already very interesting
um and so i'll tell you about um
self-testing physical theories which is
essentially a way to apply those those
networks of classical or quantum systems
or also with more general systems but
kind of an application of all those
techniques that that ellie has already
already introduced us to
um and the the work i i will be
presenting is is based on on two
projects so one is with roger callback
and the other is with um quite a quite a
group of collaborators so marco is here
and and also miguel um
from here okay
so now why do i think that that networks
can can tell us something about about
the foundations of quantum theory and i
think what comes to mind as a physicist
is
um
bell's theorem right because really what
i mean ellie already has has told us
that um we are essentially in in this
graph um in bel's theorem so so as a as
a physicist i think of two parties alice
and bob who sit somewhere space like
separated um and they they they are
shared some system and then they can put
and choose measurements to to perform on
this system
okay and and and then then in this case
this will be a quantum system here that
is shared and
um and then i can compare this what
would happen if i had a hidden variable
model where this where this lambda would
be would be classical and as compared to
early i now um when i have kind of
observed variables um i i also put the
circles but when
in the other case i just don't put a
circle around and this means it can be
either classical or quantum depending on
what i'm what i'm considering
okay um and so then in in this
particular scenario um we know um that
okay if we if we observe things
um we can get if you look at the outcome
distributions
of of these measurements conditioned on
on the inputs the measurement choices um
we we know that in the classical case we
have this usual way to to to find the
probability so a depends on lambda and x
and b on y and lambda
and and in the quantum case then we have
here a quantum state so this this this
if you if you're not familiar with this
it doesn't matter um it's just um a way
to have if if the part is our space like
separated independent measurements that
they do on some on some shared system
okay and what we know is that actually
in in in this case with quantum systems
we can recover
any such if we think of this as this
this probability distribution space we
can recover everything that we can that
we can get in classical uh classically
but but there is more
okay
um and then the way we usually think
about this is in terms of in terms of of
some figure of merit so we define some
figure of marriage to evaluate then the
theories um and usually we do this with
some some some
um linear linear functional in this in
this space and where where then the
different theories get get get different
values and an intuitive way to think
about this linear functional can be in
terms of a game where depending then on
the on the essentially the the outcome
distributions the the parties um
generate they they get a different score
so the way to think then is is let's say
now we think that the inputs and
outcomes are just binary so we can think
of a referee who asks alison bob
questions
um which which will be in this case the
x and y
um and depending on these questions and
they will they will have to generate
answers that they return to the to the
referee and the referee then has a
condition to evaluate them okay and the
most famous way to do this is with what
is called the chsh game
where
then
the the condition according to which
they're evaluated is that when both get
input one
um they should should be perfectly
anti-correlated give perfectly
anti-correlated answers and in all other
cases they should give perfectly
correlated answers
okay and now it turns out that that in
this case if you look at with what
probability they can win this game
and this is one of those of those way to
to distinguish the theories um so here
this is the probability that the referee
chooses uniformly from the set of
questions
they generate generate
their answers and then it's evaluated
according according to this and the
score in the in the classical case
um is is is the the best they can do is
is
um three-quarters whereas in the in the
quantum case they can go up to about 85
roughly
okay and and in the classical case to
think about the strategy so so one way
to achieve this would be that they just
just take this this random variable
lambda this hidden variable and they
just if this is a uniform random
variable that
that gives you zero or one with with
equal probability um they could
could just output this
um if they get the same variable then in
three quarter of the cases they're
perfectly correlated which means they
achieve those three-quarters
and this is way to think intuitively
about about those those spell bell tests
essentially um and then okay this is
something that we know um and has also
been been experimentally done so there
have been various loophole free belt
tests
um three three main ones and that i'm
aware of um where people have really
really um kind of implemented those
networks and and the difficult part or
one of the difficult part is kind of get
the networks right by really having the
people far apart and space like
separation and
and to kind of kind of really get get um
uh get this right okay and and of course
the network is crucial because if the
parties were too close together they
could communicate um and if they can
communicate about what questions they
got of course in it we will be more in
this network where of course that the
nature of the of the land that doesn't
doesn't play a role for the for the
conditional distributions
okay and and so this is already a place
where the network is crucial for in
essentially for us to to tell us more
about quantum theory in the sense that
we can rule out local hidden variable
models for it okay and this kind of a
way to to to think okay so maybe really
they these networks are
are fundamental in this respect
um now we can go a step further
and then think about well
um
so the network is important for ruling
out classical theory for instance um but
could it be that the network already
essentially tells us somehow that we're
in in the quantum world
okay and this turns out not to be the
case and this was realized by by popesco
and rory
um who who found
so these are essentially the equality
constraints that eli had in his talk
just written a bit differently um and
and so what they found is that indeed
these are not sufficient to to
reduce us to to quantum correlations in
in this set
um but they found what is now known as
the professor leaf box
that that indeed indeed um is way out
the quantum set and wins the chsh game
with probability one so if you can go
beyond quantum theory but still be
compatible essentially with special
relativity because you still have the
right independencies um you can go
further
okay and then this caused kind of a
whole essentially research research
direction to emerge i would say where
where people were then looking for for
ways to to argue why we're actually um
observing quantum theory and at one of
those other theories which which could
also make sense
and there have been many principles
people have have have then proposed to
actually recover recover the quantum
predictions
and usually the idea is that okay if you
would have these more general
correlations for instance this pr box um
this would have consequences for
instance for information processing and
for for other things you could do
um and then if you find that these
consequences are are unnatural um then
you can essentially
um argue that because of this maybe we
we are dealing dealing with with quantum
theory and from a more physical point of
view than just okay we we don't get
the thing we want
um
okay but then okay as i just said um but
then somehow this doesn't completely
work so one thing is that there could
still be non-signaling correlations that
are not quantum in the world somehow and
we just haven't figured out how to build
a device that that generates them
i mean just because it's unnatural it
doesn't mean that they couldn't be there
and and we could be surprised
um and so
this is one drawback of this approach i
would say that this we could not exclude
um and the second one is that somehow
the principles don't don't fully work
and this is something that goes back
also to miguel and his collaborators um
that indeed most of those principles
have been shown to recover not quantum
correlations but a slightly larger set
which is known as the almost quantum
correlations
okay and so this way of approaching this
problem doesn't fully work
um and so somehow then then we need we
need
something else to to to look at this
okay
and so now um one thing that actually um
we can then do is we can ask well maybe
the bell scenario is just not the right
way to look at the problem but maybe
networks can help us okay maybe we can
put quantum systems into larger networks
and maybe then we can we can say more
okay and this is essentially i would say
the idea behind a self-test of quantum
theory
okay when we change the network what can
happen to these sets of correlations is
that somehow the relation changes
so why in the bell network there are
various theories generalized
probabilistic theories that elio already
mentioned that get those those more
general correlations for instance having
pr boxes
um
and and and these have those problems
that i just mentioned if we change the
network it it may be that quantum theory
is is optimal among all those
generalized probabilistic theory with
respect to some
information processing tasks and then
this is a new way to to look at the
problem
because um if we if we find a task a
network and then a task on it where
quantum is is uniquely optimal first of
all we can actually experimentally
exclude those other theories that that
we could never do in in this scenario
and the second thing is we can do is if
we have this this also points to a
physical principle underlying quantum
theory in kind of a new way because it
doesn't tell us in in what sense other
theories are unnatural but it tells us
in in what sense quantum theory is
special
um
yes
can you just explain what you mean by
optimal
in this context okay so i would i would
have a network and then i would have
parties who also have inputs and make
outputs
and and i would define again a game or
some some relation on this some figure
of merit
and
then there is a maximum that you that
you can achieve in let's say this
generalized probabilistic theory
framework and optimal i would mean that
quantum achieves the maximum the maximum
value which in in the chsh game and the
usual bell scenarios is not is not the
case
okay thanks
i think there is someone else racing
there
i mean maybe just because there's
already
can you just explain to me the thought
behind that that is
if someone says here's an explanation
for why the physical universe
does something and you say oh but that's
the optimal way to win a quantum game
that involves such and such you know
payoffs and blah
i mean what's the thought that that god
wanted us to be able to play games
efficiently i mean i just don't even
understand how that connects with
physics okay yes okay so i guess this is
a step towards it but
so okay so of course then there is a
step going from so so the first what i
would like to do and this is what what i
would say is a self-test um of a
physical theory if you have a point
where it's uniquely extremely in this
work and then the implications i guess
the experimental test comes relatively
directly but at this point to then um
extract the physical principle out of it
is not immediate so i wouldn't say the
game is the physical principle but you
will find aspects that you need of
quantum theory um and that other
theories don't have that otherwise you
would find natural as well and then i
think these aspects will
i would hope will guide me to actually
find find a way to physically explain it
yes so i guess it's a way to see where
to look somehow
um
yes
okay
um and so so this is this is uh
kind of the task i i
um we have been addressing and and we're
also still addressing and other people
are as well um
with this approach
okay so now how could we go about this
so i said let's change the network so so
let's go let's start from this i now
named bob charlie for reasons that that
will become very clear later and but
let's assume alice and charlie now play
the chsh game okay and we're we're in
this in this scenario
so now how could i adapt the network to
to maybe maybe see something interesting
so of course okay the easiest way to
adapt it is to to split the two
uh but that that gets even worse now
this is no good because now now they
have independent sources and now um for
instance a strategy that i told you
before where they use the lambda to
generate their outputs that that doesn't
work anymore
um but what we can now do is we can
actually um use those sources and and
and um share whatever is shared here in
in the classical case a copy of it or in
the quantum case a shared state
uh with a third party
um and that's bob okay we call him bog
now bob has access to these now if you
think in this classical strategy that i
mentioned before
so now of course still alice and charlie
are are actually not uh they don't they
don't share a resource so they cannot
cannot um use the strategy from before
but what can happen is that now bob
knows um what
what resource they get
and so conditioned on him
observing that they are perfect get
perfectly correlated resources they
cannot win again the chsh game
and he knows even more he also knows if
the resources are anti-correlated
um and so what he can do if
we can okay what we can now do is define
a game where bob can choose whether they
play a game where alice should be
and charlie should be perfectly
correlated in three quarters of the
cases or one where they should be
perfectly anti-correlated and now if you
do that they will again win with
three-quarter probability overall
okay um and
so so this is a way and and in the in
the network it just means we add this
collider here
um
okay and so this now means that we can
essentially define um in this larger
network um a game or a task where they
they will retain their their winning
probability
um and now
okay we can
use this idea also in the quantum case
in the quantum case it's a bit more
complicated um so they will in in this
case when they win the chsh game
optimally they share maximally entangled
states but there is a way for bob to
measure maximally entangled states so
that conditioned on his outcome
alice and charlie will share a maximally
entangled state and so then there is a
similar reasoning to the classical
reasoning i i just introduced you to
where you can then say okay if if bob is
allowed to choose which
um of a selection of of similar games
they are allowed to win they can retain
the quantum probability from the chsh
game and so this is what what this
expresses so here here bob has
four outcomes because we want to retain
the quantum the quantum probability as
well
um and and each of those is essentially
a version of of the chsh condition that
that i've i've introduced you to before
okay and so this way we can we have we
have a way to to retain um like the the
the classical as well as the quantum
probabilities
but now this is not necessarily the case
if we look at other theories
okay and so this is exactly why then we
hope that with this
um we can we can rule out other theories
because they cannot retain their
performance when we put this this
essentially essentially uh
uh
collider in between and maybe to try to
get the physical intuitions or one thing
i mean this kind of means that when we
have strong strong resources between
certain parties that somehow we can have
parties in between that that distribute
them around and maybe in some sense
these resources can be transmitted over
or over longer distances and this could
be kind of an uh
maybe an avenue towards then finding a
physical physical reason reason for this
okay um and so what we find then is
really that okay
so
this this this proposed game or
experiment allows us to to rule out the
variety of these generalized
probabilistic theories that people have
come up with
and these are quite exotic versions of
them so they are quite far away from
from what quantum theory looks like um
there are two main things we can we can
essentially use for this one is um we
can use the the type of system
composition that you use to to build
joint state spaces from single ones
and the other thing is that also the the
single system state spaces themselves
can can already have implications for
for for for those games and so there are
kind of in in there are various cases
where we kind of encounter this this
this diagrammatic situation that that
from before where really um these
theories were
were more more general or considered
more general in the bell scenario um but
it turns out that that in a different in
a different um
a network this is not the case anymore
so somehow this this relation turns over
okay so i i don't really want to want to
define those those theories but one
thing that um
that okay i said already is that that
they're quite quite exotic quite far
away from from quantum theory but
they're also generalized probabilistic
theories that are similar for
to uh quantum theory okay for instance
quantum theory over real hilbert spaces
and this is this is very similar to to
to quantum theory and this this will
perform exactly the same in this
adaptive chsh game that i've introduced
you to okay so this is all
constructed in a way that that this this
also works
um but now what we found that there is
also good news because the network
itself allows us to find a more
sophisticated game where
indeed also the two of them
show a difference
okay and this is um
uh the the the work that also marco and
and miguel uh who are here uh
uh were very involved in and i want to
now uh spend uh the rest of this talk
essentially to
um um introduce you to to essentially
how how this works and and what the game
is to do this
okay so in this case the picture is a
bit different because we don't have that
the situation
kind of reverses in some areas but
really we essentially get will get a
better resolution of different theories
that that were not different in in
the the bell network
okay and i think this is the most
interesting generalized probabilistic
theory actually one can look at and in
that sense um
yes i will focus on that
okay
so
okay so now for this we need quantum
theory though and
um i don't know how familiar everyone is
so
essentially
the the well what
we can see is that quantum theory and
real quantum theory um kind of followed
the same the same
axioms
except that the complex hilbert's phase
is replaced by a real hilbert space so
we work with mixed state so a state is a
density operator on the hilbert space
that is positive and has has trace one
we have a composition that is given by
the tensor product
and there is an evolution this will not
be important for the talk though so
maybe we'll skip that
um and and measurements are then so the
probabilities that this is something
we've already kind of seen but i told
you not to pay attention to it is given
by by by the born rule okay so there is
some some
some
um measurement operators that that we
apply to the state in order to
obtain obtain a probability of of the
various outcomes
okay um
so now
these are two theories and and they look
very similar so then one of the
questions one would ask first is well
are they even different is there what is
what what is what is the situation there
um
okay and they do have different
properties so if we look at the smallest
the smallest system we can consider so
in quantum theory we usually
speak about the qubit which is a system
on a block sphere
um
and and in in real quantum theory
essentially we can we can drop the
the sigma y component so so we're
restricted just just to a plane
um now
what happens if we want to describe
several systems or a larger system a two
qubit system okay so in the in the
um
complex case what we can do is is
characterize the system completely again
with those with those poly measurements
okay so what we could do in order to to
find the state of such a two qubit
system is really to do all those
measurements and we get back
um and and we can completely describe
the state of the of the two qubit system
um but now in the in the case of real
quantum theory this this is not the case
um so in this case the the accent said
plane is not is not sufficient for this
and and i think the simplest way to see
this is with an example
so assume we have this this maximally
entangled state that i call call 5 plus
and it's going to come up again later
um so if i write it in in this way that
i that i wrote this here then then we
have um
this this state okay and you can see
that it's real here there is nothing
nothing complex about it
um but now just by looking at sigma x
and sigma z said value matrices i i can
see that
i cannot really fully fully um determine
the state of this by just looking at
local
local parts because the sigma y sigma y
contribution is there
okay and because sigma y is not
something i can i can locally access um
in a
in a
real quantum theory this means that
somehow this theory has has global
degrees of freedom that cannot be
accessed by by doing local things and
this is what we say when we say it
doesn't satisfy local tomography because
in quantum theory we can always do
everything by by just accessing systems
systems locally
uh okay and so so so somehow from a
physical point of view this is this is
our two quite different aspects that
that theories theories may have i would
say
um so then the other question one can
ask well why did you even think the
theories um
would or are uh are the same then maybe
then if we know this maybe it's natural
to say that that they lead to different
correlations as well
um and okay the reason is that
before i've kind of already uh mentioned
this a little bit so so if we look at at
about scenario or another scenario where
there are measurements performed on a
single state
um it turns out that that there is no
difference in the in the
correlations you can you can generate
and this goes actually back quite far so
this is the first work i know that did
such a construction is work in the 60s
by stickleberg and then there were also
more kind of quantum information and
more multipartite accounts of it of it
later
um the way this works um is like this
so so a real simulation of of
essentially this this strategy on on
um
a larger larger littlebird space and can
be made using using this
okay so essentially intuitively what i
would think of here is if you think in
the complex quantum picture what you
essentially add is some control system
for for each measurement that controls
whether you apply the measurement or its
complex conjugate
and what is nice about this is then you
can see that by taking the complex
conjugate of this of this
operator that
indeed it's going to be itself so it's a
real operator that we defined in this
way
and for the for the state similarly we
just add one of those control
um systems for each of the measurements
separate measurements we're gonna we're
gonna perform on it and again we can see
that it's real
um and we can plug this in here and and
see that we recover any any possible
um correlations that we could have had
in the complex case okay we need a
slightly larger hilbert space but we
didn't put any restriction on anything
like that so so this simulation is is
perfectly fine
okay and so then how could we how could
we
distinguish the two and
the
uh
well
the partial answer is so this this
construction doesn't go through anymore
uh naturally in the in the buy local
network and so this is a candidate where
we can again look for for a difference
um and this is what we did so
essentially what we were looking for is
to find find the distribution here at
the at the boundary of the quantum set
somewhere that seemed to be kind of
genuinely complex in in the way it was
constructed and then essentially show
that this cannot cannot be recovered
with with real quantum states and
measurements
um and
this is the candidate distribution
okay so again what we we have a similar
intuition to before that that pop the
part in the middle will essentially swap
maximally entangled states uh to to
alice and charlie
um and then alice does a measurement
that is that is um
all three police so so this seems
genuinely complex and and a similar
thing for for charlie okay and this is
now a candidate where you can think okay
maybe this is difficult or not possible
to recover in in real quantum theory
um
okay um
okay i added a bit about the intuition
why this distribution
so it turns out that that this
distribution there is a bell inequality
and that it satisfies maximally which is
a called the triple chsh inequality and
there is a result which is um a
self-test within quantum theory so which
means that if you have this distribution
you can essentially know which states
and measurements you had within the
quantum formula so now rather than
testing which theory in a more general
framework
in self-testing in quantum theory you
usually test which state the
measurements you had if you
generated a certain a certain
distribution okay and it turns out that
that um
with these these uh
states and measurements that i mentioned
before um they essentially do such a
self-test for for in in the in the bell
scenario
okay and then essentially what our our
um candidate distribution is essentially
taking these apart and putting bob in in
between to to swap the entanglement
around
uh
okay
so i think this is as much intuition as
as i can give about it then it's it's
really about about um
kind of doing doing the computation and
seen seeing that it works
um
okay and this is well what we did
so
um
what we tried then is is to see if we
have here real states
um and real measurements um can we
recover this this distribution p-bar
and as i well it was kind of clear from
from what i said before uh you cannot
okay we have here a slightly more more
general um
more general scenario because in
addition um to to having independent
sources we we also allow shared
randomness
so this is okay because somehow
um we can we can still prove the result
and so it's more general
but also um
for experiments this is this is very
important and we would like to have this
experimentally tested because somehow if
you have independent sources you still
have to synchronize your your experiment
so that
so that um
in the end i mean one doesn't
uh not one source prepares a photon
today and one prepares one tomorrow but
that they coincide at the right time at
essentially bob station so he can he can
do the experiment
and so a synchronization is is kind of
always important and and so so this was
also important that we um actually do
this slightly more generally
okay and so what we then assume is
instead of having a product state we
have essentially here a separable state
so this probability i won't
think about
in the state the important thing is
there is no shared quantum resource
between all three otherwise this this
wouldn't go through okay
um also one thing i want to mention so
so we don't have a dimension bound here
on on the on the real quantum thing so
it's really saying that with real
quantum systems and measurement of any
dimension you cannot recover this so
it's really a gap and and something you
cannot do
okay and the result is also so this is
just for this specific distribution this
is also uh noise robust
um in the sense that we can even find a
large enough gap so so that that this
can be done can be done experimentally
okay um
and and this relies on on convex
optimization uh techniques to to find
good bounds on on real quantum quantum
systems here
okay
yes i think
then
yes okay there have been experimental
implementations as well as well already
so i'm aware of three actually and the
first one was was very short after after
our
our result came out um this is with
super conducting qubits and in this case
yes
um
uh everything is is on on one chip
essentially so so in this case it's not
so clear that that this this independent
sources assumption is it has been
implemented yet
um and then there are two more so these
are from different papers um
from these two and they're with optical
optical experiments
um
so so in this case the sources are
really independent and and this part
works there are some some detection
loopholes open open though so so somehow
with different loopholes open things
have been done but not in a in a
loophole free freeway as as we we have
with the bell test okay and so somehow
um yes this has been part partially
refuted that we cannot have a
quantum theory of a real hilbert's basis
okay so
summary so um
okay so i i hope to have have convinced
you that that networks are a very useful
tool if we want to see about um
ruling out uh different of those
generalized probabilistic theories
people are researching
okay and and and these also include
theories that for instance in the usual
bell scenario are more
non-local than than quantum theory
um at the same time um
and specifically a quantum theory over
over real hilbert spaces can be excluded
in this way and this has even been
experimentally done
um with loopholes still but i think
there's there's good good good
indication that this will be closed soon
as well so so this this works um
okay now
what what more is there to do so i think
a lot actually um so for for one thing
there are other other theories one could
come up with in this generalized
parabolistic theory framework and and
theories people come up with um and so
so really having having a statement that
quantum theory is if possible uniquely
optimal somewhere would would be very
powerful because it could rule out also
future theories we can come up with
um
and so so this is this is i think still
a very interesting question whether
whether there is is such a network and
and such a top task where also many
things many things still have to be
clarified
um then in the next step it would be
nice to to then bring bring these
insights to to some axiomatic
um way to recover quantum theory
um from from from features that that we
learn learn from these from these
network tests
um and and as a last thing i think um
this also shows that that somehow these
networks all of a sudden can bring us
new avenues to look at quantum
foundations and i think we've just taken
essentially the the next general network
after the after the bell scenario and i
think looking at really a variety of
networks and looking what else they can
tell us i think is is very exciting and
i think a lot of
a lot of uh
research potential is still
still in this approach also now that we
have all those all those techniques that
that ellie has introduced us to and so i
think this is very exciting and i'd like
to thank you
thank you very much uh are there any
questions from the audience
yes
very quickly because this is not just
not the way i think about things um
i would have thought at least
theoretically not experimentally instead
of chsh ghz would be better
i mean it's cleaner right the the
restrictions for ghc are cleaner has
that is that something people are
looking at
green burger corn and zion
three-part
that's right
triple triple entangled state with
perfect correlations the green burger
horn and zion people don't know that
oh my gosh okay
isn't that a natural thought to how the
things go with that it's just a it's a
stronger concern
it's a non-statistical constraint but if
she doesn't know what it is i can't ask
no i don't know what what the gh says
that's basis
i don't know because i'm not a quantum
person i'm a satisfaction hornets
islander in this conference
i'm sorry this is a little so
he's quite people playing just like her
answer
okay so okay maybe i can write this
style nope there is a thing called the
green burger horn and zeilinger state
and it's a state that instead of having
just this maximally entangled state that
i mentioned so what i what we were
looking at in the in the bell scenario
is a state that looks like this so we
just have have two two systems that can
be accessed so this was the five plus i
was working with
and then there is also a gh set state um
i guess we normalize as well no that's
not it
that is not the g side state
it's a superposition of four
it's an equal superposition of four
different entire three particle states
it's not a two it's not a two do you
mean w state maybe this would be
i mean the g zero zero one already
one zero zero
and then i guess you have the one do you
need this one or no
yeah okay so i think this is okay so
maybe you have a different terminology
so for me this is a w state i think or
in the w state family maybe um
so i mean you need the right
minus sign
okay ah you have some okay
c
d with okay
with some coefficients so
okay um
you get perfect predictions for
you get perfect predictions not
statistical predictions
for
the mermaid square maybe merman merlin
wrote a nice paper about ghz
so if you've read merman you should know
ghz
okay so i think
sorry
so it doesn't make any sense so you
cannot violate
that mechanism is one of these
inequalities but you go to the
experiment for the correlation
but
that was my original point to say at
least theoretically
i understand their experimental problems
it's harder to make ghd sticks okay
but theoretically you have these perfect
predictions
you have a theory and you can ask if
there are other theories that make the
same predictions forget about
okay so i think maybe we have one of
those theory of the same prediction for
that experiment
okay i think okay maybe maybe uh
sorry i thought it was a simple question
no no it's okay i mean i think we also i
thought we were speaking about the gh
state and apparently not so i think we
had uh have some different terminology
maybe we should talk in a break maybe
what i can say say quickly so in
principle so the trick of whenever you
have a i bipartisan the trick with
putting bob in the middle and seeing
whether you get good good separations we
have also tried this for other well
inequalities so this works now if you're
asking about going to a to a three-part
eye test
then i think the analysis becomes more
complicated and so this we haven't we
haven't actually done and and i don't
know
um
but but in principle i mean the
playground is huge now you can think if
you have a three-part i think and you
share a state you can you can then ask
well how if i put put
um
put more parties in between can i can i
maybe do a similar argument but i think
it's not as not as natural in this sense
because we know this bell state
measurement and we know that we have
entanglement swapping and this is
something that the idea was very much
based on and for instance if you have
three parties then
it's not so clear where you would put
put the person in between that mediates
and how you combine the different
sources
and so i think there i mean it's very
interesting and there are many things to
be to be answered there but but at this
stage we have not looked into this
okay i guess we're out of time now so
let's thank our speaker again